woke up at 1 went to go get coffee and
it was on dude and then I went to the
desert ridge improv and I met Brian
Callen and I did stand up uh for his
crowd uh and then we roasted each other
afterwards a video is coming on my other
YouTube channel be ready for it
dude now let me ask you a question Brian
Ken how come when I'm with you I also
always have to meet 12
guys you have too many people around you
all the time time and that's very weird
because you're not Eddie
Griffin and that's very weird because
you're not Chingy and that's very weird
because you're not bis Marquee in 1988
and that's very weird do you know what I
mean
why you're not Murphy Lee and that's
very weird I don't know why but every
time I go to to to
see Brian Ken somewhere and here's the
deal dude we're really good
friends
um and we hang out mostly at business
stuff and you could tell that because
you find me on a place of business but
you could find it you you you mostly
hang out at business stuff right um and
we hang out of business stuff podcasts
you know stand up sometimes we'll shoot
a video you together sometimes we'll
sometimes we'll hang out but not often
often it's a business up whenever I see
them there are also 12 guys with him and
it is
always
always always there are always four like
four guys that own a
gym you know like three of them will be
will own one gym and then one of them
will own a separate gym and then there
will be some sort of criminal around too
always and I'm telling you
always and then there's like a
45-year-old hot chick somewhere that is
dating one of them and then another guy
that like I I didn't even like once I
leave I completely forget him and I'll
never think of him again but it's always
hey Brian count I don't want to also and
you know what bring 12 guys around for
real bring 12 guys around but don't
introduce me to them because I don't
know them and I'm gonna now you know oh
I'll give you because he be like oh I'll
give you you got that friend like I'll
give you the number you guys can connect
next time you're out here you do the
okay
nice enough the nicest guys but I
remember one time I
was I was like yeah I was doing the
Irvine Improv this was a long time ago
and he's just one of those guys dude
where he says oh dude my friends want to
come to your show they're so good
they're so cool can we just can you get
them a ticket can you meet them
afterward I said okay yeah dude it was
like some dude that was 50 something and
two 25-year-old drunk like uh
like actual porn actresses and they were
just like Hey we're friends at Brian C
he was like Hey his name was something
like [__] bbop you know and I'm just
like and I'm like
Brian
don't
don't anyway I met 12 guys one of them
was Sammy the bulano you know for real
honestly
one of them was Sammy the bul Grano and
I'm like okay um anyway dude then I went
to go up on stage and I did the the
Brian Kum thing and it was fun